l'expulsion de l'équipe festina du tour
de france les larmes de richard virenque
qui se voit contraint d'abandonner le
tour une décision spectaculaire après
l'aveu d'un dopage organisé au sein de
cette équipe en direct avec nous en
platini le président de l'organisation
du tour il nous expliquera cette
expulsion nous parlerons de ses
conséquences et du dopage qui
empoisonnent les milieux du sport
témoignages également direct de gilles
delion cet ancien coureur qui a quitté
le tour il ya deux ans et qui dénonce
haut et fort les pratiques de dopage
création d'une cour pénale
internationale 120 pays malgré
l'opposition des états unis ont donné
naissance à cette instance qui jugera
les crimes contre l'humanité et puis une
page spéciale consacrée aux magnifiques
le festival d'aix-en-provence un nouveau
souffle pour cette manifestation d'art
lyrique qui fête son 50e anniversaire
madame monsieur bonsoir l'actualité de
ce jour marqué par le séisme qui touche
le tour de france avec l'expulsion ce
matin de l'équipe phare l'équipe vedette
de festina un événement d'une portée
considérable une affaire qui marquera un
tournant dans l'histoire du sport
cycliste avec l'avant festina il après
nous reviendrons tout au long de ce
journal sur cette affaire de dopage qui
salit le sport nous aurons joly dit en
direct jean claude killy président de la
société du tour nous écouteront aussi le
témoignage de cet ancien coureur qui
dénonce les pratiques du dopage mais
d'abord les larmes de richard virenque
eux l'enfant chéri du public
le leader de l'équipe festina il n'a pas
été autorisé à prendre le départ de la
7e étape dans la matinée il a joué le
bras de fer
finalement il a renoncé jeudi vega l'isi
florent gautreau panique dans un café à
quelques mètres de la ligne d'arrivée le
directeur du
rendez vous avec l'équipe festina une
page de l'histoire du cyclisme s'est
écrite alors dans ce bar 20 minutes de
huis clos c'est ce qu'ils n'accèdent ils
ne prendront pas le départ de la course
comme il l'avait annoncé
confusion et déceptions juridiquement on
aurait pu continuer le tour de france
parce que dans cette affaire il ya eu
des coupables et ils sont écroués
nous on est seulement des témoins donc
pour le sport pour le vélo pour le tour
de france
on quitte le tour et je remercie le
public qui a été très très qui nous a
énormément soutenu et qui va encore nous
soutenir et mai prochains
richard virenque parler du feuilleton de
l'été
c'était le dernier épisode pour festina
un épisode qui laisse au monde cycliste
un goût amer a ajouté que la direction
du tourisme veut bien au revoir aux
coureurs de festina parce
qu'individuellement
nous n'avons rien contre les cours a
simplement collectivement le groupe a
comme une faute
ironie de l'histoire festina le
chronométreur officiel du tour n'aura
pas couru le premier contre-la-montre 30
millions d'investissements qui
s'envolent en fumée
ce soir le sponsor restaient toujours
muets depuis l'arrestation du soigneur
de richard virenque puis celle du
directeur sportif et du médecin de
l'équipe festina
les événements se sont précipités riche
en rebondissements avec hier soir les
aveux d'un dopage organisé et
systématique ou sein même de l'équipe
le film depuis cette nuit avec l'autre
sans père et parce qu'elle joue c'est
bon 20h15 hier soir le sourire figé
bruno roussel part pour la prison
d'arras où il passera la nuit
eric ryckaert le médecin de l'équipe et
lui aussi mis en examen et écroué à ce
moment là bien peu savent quel coup de
théâtre vient de se jouer l'avocat de
bruno roussel est de ceux là
pas de question réponse ce soir thibault
de montbrial se contentera d'un
communiqué l'importance mais la lyre mot
amour pardon
tous les mois
monsieur bruno roussel a expliqué aux
enquêteurs lesquels avaient les éléments
les conditions dans lesquelles une
gestion concertée de l'approvisionnement
des coureurs en produits dopants était
organisée entre la direction les
médecins
le soigneur et les coureurs l'objectif
était d' optimiser les performances sous
strict contrôle médical afin d'éviter
d'approvisionnement personnel sauvage
des coureurs dans des conditions
susceptibles de porter gravement
atteinte à leur santé comme ça a pu être
le cas par le passé sur le tour hier
soir à brive ce communiqué de l'avocat
fait l'effet d'une bombe
à 22h50 je marie leblanc le directeur du
tour improvise une conférence de presse
pour annoncer une décision sans
précédent nous avons pris la décision
d'exclure l'équipe festina du tour de
france à compter de ce jour
décision difficile car nous avons
beaucoup pensé aux coureurs
mes décisions qui nous paraissait
indispensable et que nous espérons
salutaire retranchés dans leurs châteaux
hôtels les coureurs garde le silence
seul le directeur sportif adjoint des
festina réagir vivement s'aperçoit qu'on
est lancé et que surtout unis veulent
qu'on se suicide pour être tous très
propre est ce que vous vous dites on
veut faire de nous les boucs émissaires
c'est clair on va être et où on veut
qu'on soit les boucs émissaires dès 9
heures ce matin jean-françois pescheux
se pose en hélicoptère près du château
le directeur sportif du tour vient
signifier officiellement leur explosion
euros festina la tension monte
des chars des reins qui a bien du mal à
se maîtriser
le champion veut absolument prendre le
départ de l'étape
une question d'honneur et on imagine
aisément l'émotion des supporteurs de
richard grant lorsqu'ils ont appris que
le sportif vedette et ses coéquipiers
était exclue du tour
un seul sujet de conversation la
décision est elle inévitable
alexandre kara nathalie gallet la grande
boucle c'est aussi le tour du monde les
spectateurs nombreux qui peuplent le
bord des routes et encourage les héros
les spectateurs heureux ou malheureux au
gré des péripéties du tour c'est une
tragédie pour moi on était venu pour ça
pour les pour laisser porter et bon et
s'il exclut le festival devrait exclure
moi je dis que c'est un peu dégueulasse
pour les coureurs est d'y soigner une
seule équipe nous manquer c'est le tour
qui perd de son intérêt le tour sans
festina c'est un peu comme en été sans
soleil c'est toujours le tour mais c'est
quand même moins bien que j'étais venu
déjà encouragé richard comme toute
l'équipe festina marche bien qua non à
partir d'aujourd'hui on ne sait même pas
s'ils veulent regarder chez moi
franchement je suis très déçu vraiment
le tour comme les gens attendent on sait
tous qu'on peut en dire il est la plus
forte des meilleurs la montagne n'est
pas marché et cela quelles étaient les
meilleures
depuis ce matin on en même temps c'est
pas normal c'est c'est pas beau c'est
pas bien on va pas suivre en ben non on
n'est pas content d'être venu et puis
voilà
et puis avant le tout ça ne fait pas
bonne impression on aimerait bien que
les grands montrent le bon exemple
c'est sûr qu'elle richard berens
compagnies sont un grand champion mais
ça casse un peu leur image
dommage et même si le public va ce
fidèle aux coureurs il faudra du temps
pour dissiper les nuages de la perf
estime et servir un qu'avec clairement
annoncé son intention de gagner le tour
cette année il s'y était préparé avec
lui tous ses supporteurs qui va
aujourd'hui la fin d'un beau rêve
ils ont difficilement résister aux
sanglots du sportif qui s'est résigné à
abandonner au premier plan la mère de
richard virenque ont rencontré à
carqueiranne dans le var olivier théron
et jean-paul berling et rongeurs
virenque ne peut empêcher ses larmes de
couler son fils richard lui aussi pleure
en annonçant son retrait du tour de
france
c'est une fête qui se transforme en
tragédie
elle y croyait cette année la maman
comme son fils à une victoire possible
dans la grande boucle
alors le dopage la suspicion le scandale
qui tourne autour de festina elle
préfère ne pas en parler c'est richard
qui l'intéressent on n'a plus rien à
dire moi personnellement j'ai rien à
dire je suis vraiment eu resterez de
voir ce qui s'est passé et je plais tous
les coureurs et je suis très près de mon
fils et voilà ici au fan club du rhin
que c'était le chichi le leader de la
meilleure équipe du monde
cette exclusion alors que les contrôles
antidopage sont négatifs est perçu comme
une injustice flagrante
on attendait tous qu'ils finissent
premiers pas c'est pas qu'on l'attendait
c'est qu'on le savait on en était sûrs
donc jeudi un rebond bas si vous voulez
tous les témoignages qu'on reçoit les
le milieu de gens qui nous appellent qui
nous écrivent et bien cela sent comme
nous il attendait mais manifestement ça
devait dérangé du monde pas parce que
qu'on passe pas mal et que c'était un
coup monté que moi je suis confiant
richard parce que il m'a avoué à
plusieurs reprises et de manière
familiale que jamais y toucher à ces
produits
personnellement je suis content pour eux
le tour s'est arrêté aujourd'hui ils
attendent maintenant le retour de
richard et sa prochaine course en
espagne
peut-être au fil des jours c'est une
atmosphère délétère presque irrespirable
qui entourait la caravane la nouvelle de
l'exclusion de l'équipe festina a fait
l'effet d'un coup de tonnerre peut être
salutaire
il faut que le tour continue à vivre
ambiance aujourd'hui nathalie - emmanuel
bec via mme rice le danois vainqueur il
ya deux ans qui s'amusent à faire courir
les journalistes laurent jalabert
l'autre chouchou des français qu'ils se
dépêchent de rejoindre le quart de son
équipe sur la ligne d'arrivée les
favoris ne semble pas pressé de répondre
aux questions de la presse
et quand il accepte enfin la sphère
sestina n'est pas leur sujet de
prédilection
moi je souhaite qu'on part de la course
maintenant on en a trop parlé
pourquoi la course on est sur le tour de
france a fait le jour que ces partis en
abaissant la bouche je crois qu'il
reprochait à venir maintenant ça se
résume pas qu'une simple page
aucune réaction je ne sais pas moi d'en
parler sur le tour
rares sont les coureurs qui prennent la
défense de l'équipe festina
moi je trouve que c'est pas très normal
quand même parce que les corps n'ont pas
été contrôlés positifs donc à partir de
là déjà il faut fournir les preuves
comme quoi ils ont utilisé les produits
qui a été incriminé
à partir de là on peut dire qu'ils
sanctionnent sportif qui va être
appliqué
c'est pour sauver l'image du tour c'est
ridicule al'inverse aucun coureur ne se
dit ouvertement satisfait de ce
dénouement plutôt triste à l'instar du
vainqueur du giro marco pantani
devant le tour ainsi et kaboul et l'otan
est un peu voir s'il va pas résoudre
tous à son travail
que la justice fasse son travail pour
éviter que les soupçons de dopage ne
ternisse l'ensemble des coureurs comme
pour éclaircir l'image d'un sport devenu
flou en marge de la sphère de dopage au
sein de l'équipe festina cette
révélation d'une autre saisie de
produits dopants au sein d'une autre
équipe du tour les faits remontent à
mars dernier où des mécaniciens de
l'équipe tv m aurait été arrêté
transportant des produits interdits
officiellement les membres de l'équipe
hollandaise tvm ne vois pas de quoi on
parle
en mars dernier les douaniers d'oran
sont retrouvés lors d'un contrôle à bord
d'un camion d'assistance qui rejoignait
la hollande
une centaine de seringue de péter
question de votre équipe
ah oui 9 mars je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas samantha n'est pas vraiment jamais
là vous m'apprenez vraiment une belle
non je savais pas le coureur français
laurent roux affirme ne s'être jamais
dopé mais ses propos sont ambigus vous a
déjà proposé de le paix au proposés
n'ont pas proposé
non ça me proposait on vous a déjà
présenté deux les p o
je n'ai déjà vu je sais la forme sera
même sur les chiffres damèche a déjà vu
mais comment j'ai comme je vous dis c
c'est mon choix c'est un choix c'est est
ce que vous avez dit par rapport à ça
non mais écoutez moi je dirais pas
je ne dirais pas ce que moi j'en passe
puisque c'est une chose personnelle
comme il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
dans la vie
et moi je dis simplement tout dépend ce
qu'on veut être dans le sport en fin
d'après midi le manager de l'équipe lui
a retrouvé la mémoire mais il affirme
que les produits auraient été placés à
l'insu du mécanicien il s'agirait donc
d'un acte de malveillance
en tout cas tvm a eu plus de chance que
festina le parquet n'a pas ouvert une
enquête sur cette affaire
pour l'instant
ils nous rejoignent en direct le
président de la société du tour jean
claude killy bonsoir une sale journée
pour le tour une sale journée pour y
servir ans que nous y reviendrons mais
d'une question
l'avez vous rencontrée depuis ce matin
et que lui avez-vous dit je lui ai parlé
hier soir et hier matin je lui ai parlé
tout à l'heure encore je les encourager
à à se préparer pour revenir dans le
cyclisme très rapidement après que cette
affaire était non pas éclairci mais mise
derrière lui parce qu'il était un grand
champion et qu'il va manquer au tour de
france tous les témoignages qu'on vient
d'entendre le démontre depuis l'a vu
hier soir d'un dopage organisé la
décision ensemble semble être inévitable
n'aviez pas d'autre choix vous aviez
vous avez agi sous la pression des
événements
nous avons agi en toute honnêteté nous
avons protégé les coureurs depuis le
départ d'irlande
parce que nous pensions que nous
pourrons toujours aujourd'hui que le
coureur est le dernier responsable de la
chaîne ça n'était plus possible à partir
du moment où le directeur propriétaire
de l'équipe l'avouer lui-même qu'il
était à la tête d'un système qui
permettait d'améliorer chimiquement les
les performances des coureurs nous on
nous le regrettons profondément ça
déborde largement pardon oui justement
nous allons venir sur ces affaires de
dopage
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous
expulser les couleurs de festina la
sanction activement ce mais avec le
risque de faire porter le chapeau à une
seule équipe de ne désigner qu'un seul
coupable car apparemment le dopage est
précisément et je pense que c'est ce que
voulait dire une pratique courante sur
le tour c'est une trafic un trafic
courant nous ne pouvons pas le dire nous
mêmes nous nous organisons le tour de
france aujourd'hui vous avez un
directeur d'équipé qui avoue que son
équipe se dopent vous n'avez plus à ce
moment là les moyens de laisser courir
cette équipe à l'intérieur du tour de
france parce que ça ça fausse le jeu
littéralement nous sommes obligés de
nous en tenir à ça nous organisateurs et
à appliquer le règlement et comme nous
l'appliquons d'ailleurs dans les
contrôles que nous imposons tous les
jours que ce soit des contrôles sanguins
ou des contrôles d'uriné
c'est à dire que certains d'entre vous
dans les instances de l'organisation
marquent leur surprise peut-être leur
étonnement devant l'aveu de ces
pratiques mais vous en claude killy qui
est un sportif de haut niveau qui
n'était pas quelqu'un de naïf
est ce que vous êtes vraiment étonné est
ce que c'est une découverte
je suis un peu étonné je découvre le nom
des produits affirme mesure qu'ils
sortent quasiment excepté pour le pcot
que je connais très bien puisque mon
père en prend tous les jours ou déraison
cardiaque
je suis attristé par ce que le sport
pour moi ça n'est pas du tout cela est
encore une fois je considère de choses
que les coureurs sont les plus petits
responsable de toute cette énorme
filière et et ça c'est c'est vraiment
très important et que deux quand on
prétend certains l'ont fait que 100% du
peloton et dopé
là je trouve que c'est allé un peu loin
sans preuve c'est vraiment dommage pour
le sport du cyclisme si vous voulez bien
dans un instant on va écouter la
réaction de gilles delion qui est un
ancien coureur qui a abandonné le
cyclisme il ya tout juste deux ans mais
cette dernière question à ce que
directement ou indirectement vous vous
reconnaissez une part de responsabilité
dans ces affaires qui a envoyé le milieu
mais ce qui n'aurait pas fallu un
monsieur propre que vous auriez pu être
plus tôt ces affaires viennent de sortir
celle dont on parle et connaît depuis
sept jours c'est un peu difficile de
devenir monsieur propre aujourd'hui
ou même il ya une semaine même jean
marie leblanc qui connaît très très bien
ce monsieur est un peu estomaqué un peu
surpris et déçu par les révélations qui
ont été faites alors si vous voulez bien
on va rejoindre en direct gilles delion
qui a quitté donc le cyclisme il y a
deux ans vous avez toujours dénoncé les
pratiques de dopage je voudrais une
réaction à ce que effectivement c'est
une nouveauté une découverte c'est ce
que jean claude killy a l'air de dire
est ce que c'est une découverte pour
vous ces pratiques de dopage dans le
sport
écoutez il est clair que pour nous qui
avons été dans le milieu c'est une chose
que nous connaissons très bien dans la
mesure où on en entend parler depuis des
années ça fait des années que tirer la
sonnette d'alarmé
bon ben c'est pas du tout une nouveauté
bien sûr il fallait il a fallu que la
justice s'en charge pour que pour le
faire découvrir à tous mais déjà l'an
dernier nous avions fait un dossier avec
le journal l'équipe et les vieux savez
fait déjà beaucoup de bruit
voilà c'est une péripétie plus
personnellement est-ce que vous on vous
a proposé encouragés à prendre des
produits dopants lorsque vous étiez sur
le tour lorsque j'étais coureur cycliste
pas particulièrement sur le tour mais
lorsque j'étais comme un cycliste
professionnel sur route en tout cas
puisque je suis encore vtt mais
effectivement on m'a proposé des
produits dopants oui que vous inspire
aujourd'hui l'attitude de richard
virenque et ses coéquipiers quand ils
disent se sacrifier pour le tour ne rien
avoir à se reprocher mais écoutez moi je
retiendrai quand même la déclaration
bruno roussel et au vu de cette
déclaration je trouve que les
déclarations des coureurs sont un culot
et d'une hypocrisie incroyable
il est bien clair que tout le monde
était dopé dans cette équipe
celle-là reconnu le médecin a reconnu
comment voulez-vous nier l'évidence
alors que tous les faits sont là pour le
prouver alors justement revenons à ces
pratiques vous avez reçu vous des
confidences des coureurs dans quelle
proportion les équipes sur le tour sont
sont touchés par exemple il impossible
de fixer une proportion surtout que moi
je suis plus dans le milieu cycliste
professionnel sur good depuis deux ans
donc je vais pas vous parler quelque
chose de quelque chose que je ne connais
plus
mais il est clair que c'est une pratique
assez largement répandue il ne touche
pas tout le monde mais qui est trop
répandue est justement qui se fait à
l'encontre de tous ceux qui ne veulent
pas toucher à ces produits dans quelles
proportions
il est impossible de fixer une
proportion mais la proportion est très
importante bien sûr vous parlez de
course aux glaçons dans tous les
attelles c'est à dire vous pouvez nous
expliquer cela oui disons qu'en en tout
cas pour conserver le pays je conservais
le pays ou dans le froid pour que nous
dégénère pas donc
donc c'est vrai qu'une course aux
glaçons dans les hôtels il faut
renouveler le stock de glaçons dans les
glacières pour tenir le pays
mais pour revenir à mâts d'éclairage que
je disais juste avant est clair que le
dopage ne s'arrête pas au vélo le
cyclisme n'a pas le monopole du dopage
pas plus que festina n'a le monopole du
dopage dans le vélo donc bon ça touche
tous les sports ça touche le tennis ça
touche le foot ça touche l'athlétisme et
ben on continue à avoir des termes
élogieux pour les autres sports et en
est on met à mal le vélo c'est aussi
dommage alors qu'on réserve le même
traitement à tous
alors justement peut-être on va faire
réagir jean claude killy à la fois votre
témoignage est aussi peut-être
jean claude killy comment allez-vous
réinstaller un peu d'éthique dans le
sport et le sport cyclisme
un député parle d'une enquête
parlementaire vous êtes pour jacques
chirac on écoutera tout à l'heure a fait
des déclarations sur cette malhonnêteté
qu'est le dopage
écoutez moi je crois qu'il faut mettre
toutes les parties dans la même pièce
à la fin de la saison sous l'égide de
l'uci et mettre absolument tout sur la
table
sortir de la com après qu'une charte
nouvelles étaient établis signée par
tous avec un règlement tout à fait
draconien et des déclarations sur
l'honneur à un règlement draconien qui
exclut immédiatement et définitivement
celui qui qui franchit le rubicon je ne
vois pas d'autres vous avez au cio par
exemple le tribunal arbitral du sport
vous avez la sphère ben johnson on peut
encore et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec gilles delion le dopage ne concerne
pas seulement le cyclisme c'est un
problème qui concerne tout le sport
aujourd'hui il faut absolument que nous
réagissions de la manière la plus ferme
avant que cela ne tombe mal merci jean
claude killy d'avoir répondu à nos
questions merci également à gilles
delion
l'exclusion de l'équipe festina porte un
coup à l'image de ce groupe spécialisé
dans la distribution de montres et
chronométreur officiel du tour de france
les derniers événements pourraient
l'inciter à remettre en cause sa
politique de sponsoring
mayrand frédéric bonnet que ce soit au
départ d'une étape comme aujourd'hui
avec un podium largement décoré à six
couleurs où que ce soit sitôt l'arrivée
franchie avec en bas à gauche de l'écran
mention qui apparaît et ce bien sûr dans
les 169 pays qui retransmettent le tour
à travers le monde
oui pas de doute festina dans le
cyclisme c'est un géant une équipe mais
pas seulement
on l'a compris festina et donc aussi le
chronométreur officiel du tour de france
et ce jusqu'en 2003 à raison de 5
millions francs par an le budget de
l'équipe lui est de 35 millions de
francs annuels une somme entièrement
géré jusque là par bruno roussel et sa
société pro sport basé en andorre en son
sein donc virenque d'où le dufau tous
des grands noms du cyclisme attiré
recruté par russel qui pensait avoir le
sourire et croire à sa réussite
vu les investissements mis en oeuvre
christina une marque de montres créé en
1902 racheté par un espagnol miguel
rodriguez en 1984 depuis le groupe
festina et basée à barcelone
emploie près de 130 salariés et a
réalisé un chiffre d'affaires de 100
millions de francs mais dernière rien
qu'en france outre une équipe de
cyclisme festina parraine aussi l'équipe
de basket catalan mais c'est le poids du
vélo qui est évidemment le plus
important avec richard virenque festina
avait trouvé une star
ausculté disséquer suivi dans ses
moindres faits et gestes
aujourd'hui malgré son poids économique
malgré la notoriété de festina c'est
tout un pan du cyclisme qui est passé de
la lumière vive à l'ombre la puissance
et puis en corrèze à saran jacques
chirac qui assistait à la 7e étape du
tour dans le canton où son épouse
bernadette et adjoints du maire jacques
chirac a vivement condamné l'utilisation
du dopage et de ces filières menus tout
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que on n'a
pas le droit de jouer comme ça avec la
santé de jeunes sportifs qui se laisse
ou qui peuvent se laisser en prenait et
il est tout à fait capital d'avoir une
véritable éradication des filières vont
retrouver les filières dans lesquelles
ce phénomène se développe se répand et
sanctionner je dirais sans pitié
ce qui alimente ces filières alors nous
avons eu encore là un exemple un peu
dramatique mais ça ne doit que ça doit
nous encourager à éradiquer ce mal
le tour de france avec la 7e étape
aujourd'hui à contre-la-montre de 58 km
sous le soleil encore aix et l'allemand
jan ullrich qui a endossé le maillot
jaune de leader après sa victoire de
l'étape
laurent jalabert s'est classé quatrième
dans ce contre-la-montre nos rentrées
via naulleau riche vous salue bien
l'allemand est de retour sur ses terres
c'est le seul des très grands ont le
droit de s'exprimer
58 km contre la montre entre meyrignac
l'église et corrèze a priori le terrain
idéal pour le tenant du type lancé à sa
poursuite au champion de france laurent
jalabert 1 est champion du monde du
contre la montre justement le duel est
donc annoncée mais très vite l'allemand
fait parler la poudre
il rejoint d'emblée le concurrent parti
deux minutes avant lui comme l'année
dernière dans ce genre d'exercice
le ton est donné dans le même temps
l'australien stuart o'grady s'élance en
dernier
il sait que son maillot jaune ne sera
plus sur ses épaules
une heure plus tard pour contrer le
riche laurent jalabert donc tout ce
qu'il possède sous la chaleur
corrézienne le français est certes
dominé mais il imite les dégâts ne
concédant finalement qu'il me 27
secondes
ayano riches ce dernier fait donc coup
double il gagne l'étape et devient le
nouveau maillot jaune du tour et ce dès
le 5ème soir foule riches qui devance
c'est étonnant deux américains hamilton
et boulic alors que l'espagnol olano
s'est effondré terminant à 2 minutes 12
12 h
voilà donc l'allemand déjà installé
comme son propre successeur on verra
dans les jours qui viennent si ça n'est
pas trop tôt pour lui il a pu en tout
cas offert sa tunique à jacques chirac
présent sur le tour
pour le président de la république après
le bleu voici donc john la collection de
maillots sa grande
l' affaire du sang contaminé avec les
résonances après la décision de la cour
de justice de renvoyer les trois anciens
ministres pour homicide involontaire
une décision qui ne contente personne
pas plus dans les milieux politiques que
dans les familles de victimes de nick
vers d'ailleurs virginie fils est au nom
de laurent et stéphane leurs deux fils
décédé après une contamination par
transfusion patrice et agnès gaudin
continuent leur combat jusqu'à présent
la justice n'a pas reconnu
officiellement leur statut de victime
dans l'affairé du sang contaminé
depuis six ans il milite pour le
jugement des anciens ministres il
attendait un renvoi pour empoisonnement
un crime
la décision d'hier est pour eux une
demi-victoire mirex est un semblant de
justice
c'est un semblant et on pourra
absolument pas s'en contenter pour nous
vous savez c'est cet or est pour nous on
reçoit ça comme un coup de poignard de
quand on nous dit que c'est un homicide
involontaire je voudrais comprendre et
pour comprendre je vais être présente
je vais te présente pour savoir ce que
je peux reprocher au ministre après la
justice juge rend la classe politique
elle-même se déclare choqué par le
renvoi des trois anciens ministres
françois bayrou pour force démocrate
parle d'une décision très dure et
regrette une justice de bouc émissaire
françois hollande exprimé lui sa
surprise sous-estimé tout ce qui s'est
produit sans méconnaître toutes les
tragédies je crois qu'on ne peut pas
confondre la responsabilité pénale avec
la responsabilité politique c'est dans
cette salle du palais de justice de
paris que se tiendra en 1999 ou en l'an
le procès des trois anciens ministres
ils seront jugés par trois magistrats
mais aussi par six députés et six
sénateurs
un peu plus d'un mois après la
disparition d'eric tabarly et le corps
d'un homme repêché hier au large des
côtes d'irlande pourrait bien être celui
du navigateur pour l'instant bien sûr il
faut rester prudent il n'a pas été
formellement identifié mais les
vêtements sont semblables à ceux qu'il
portait le soir du drame
thierry curty lorsque eric tabarly est
tombé de pen duick
il n'avait ni gilet de sauvetage ni
ligne de vie l'a mérité grosse il
faisait nuit
c'était il ya un mois à 40 milles au
large de milford haven
le corps repêché hier n'était qu'à une
quinzaine de milles du point de chute
le patron de l'agneby dick le chalutier
qui a remonté la macabre découverte
c'est fait d'écrire par son second
l'habillement du corps sans vie
écoutez le et des potes il avait la navy
digue s'est aussitôt dérouté pour
déposer le corps dans le port le plus
proche
la police l'a aussitôt prise en charge
et conduite à l'hôpital de waterford sud
de l'irlande
une autopsie sera pratiquée lundi les
autorités irlandaises ont précisé
qu'elle ne recherchait aucun autre corps
en ce moment puis nous venons
d'apprendre à l'instant que l'épousé
d'éric tabarly jacqueline tabarly s'est
rendu à waterford précisément pour
identifier le corps repêchés au large de
l'irlande
après des semaines de négociations et
malgré l'opposition des états unis
création d'une cour internationale de
justice
une instance permanente qui jugera les
auteurs des crimes de guerre et des
crimes contre l'humanité le nail jospin
parle aujourd'hui d'un progrès majeurs
de la conscience universelle
eric monnet l'instant est historique
l'émotion palpable
les représentants de 160 pays viennent
de donner au monde un tribunal
international permanent
il jugera des crimes les plus graves
qu'ils soient génocide crimes contre
l'humanité crimes de guerre ou
d'agression une innovation obtenu non
sans mal après cinq semaines de débats à
rome et la mauvaise volonté manifeste de
quelques pays les états unis la première
puissance mondiale aurait souhaité
pouvoir contrôler plus étroitement cette
cour de justice
elle a voté contre tout comme des pays
qui lui sont habituellement hostiles la
libye par exemple mais 120 pays ont voté
pour l'ol lui disposait déjà de
tribunaux traitant des massacres commis
dans l'ex yougoslavie et au rwanda
elle disposera désormais à l'est une
institution permanente habilitée à
engager les procédures de son propre
chef à la demande d'un état ou du
conseil de sécurité
une centaine d'albanais du kosovo
blessés lors de combats se sont réfugiés
aujourd'hui en albanie les images que
nous voyons ont été détournés du côté
serbe de nombreuses victimes au moins 30
morts du côté albanais après de violents
combats entre séparatistes du kosovo et
l'armée yougoslave
joyeux anniversaire monsieur mandela
l'afrique du sud célèbre aujourd'hui les
80 ans de cet homme qui fut enfermé 27
ans dans les prisons du régime de
l'apartheid nelson mandela le jour même
de son anniversaire a épousé sa compagne
la veuve du président du mozambique
l'archevèque desmond tout était dans
l'assistance en papouasie près d'un
millier de personnes auraient été tuées
par le raz-de-marée provoqué par un
tremblement de terre qui a touché le
pays hier une vague de dix mètres de
haut a ravagé c'est du village de la
côte nord ouest
trente minutes après que le séisme de
magnitude 7 est touché la région
je vous propose maintenant une page
spéciale dans ce journal consacré au
festival d'aix-en-provence pour cent
cinquantième anniversaire et pour
redonner un coup de fouet à cette
manifestation d'art lyrique stéphane
lissner aux côtés de bruno elle va nous
expliquera tout à l'heure en quoi aix en
provence et ses habitants sont à nouveau
impliquée dans ce rendez vous
prestigieux mais d'abord nous retrouvons
bruno alba tout près du théâtre de
l'archevêché
oui bonjour béatrice et bienvenue dans
ce lieu de charme et de
magie musicale investi il y à 50 ans par
des amoureux fou de la musique de mozart
et en quelques années après avoir
réalisé quelques magnifiques production
aix en provence est devenu un peu légal
de salzbourg la ville natale de mozart
l'un de ces temples où l'on célèbre la
musique alors comme tous les temples et
bien il avait pris un petit coup de
vieux
et aujourd'hui il reprend un petit coup
de jeune avec notamment la présence à
aix-en-provence d'une centaine de jeunes
musiciens de l'académie européenne de
musique et d'autres musiciens
extrêmement jeunes qui font partie des
orchestres qui se produisent avec les
chanteurs nous vous allez constater
cette ambiance absolument charmante ici
à aix en provence avec ce reportage de
georges bigot et michel levasseur
que voit-on à travers les persiennes les
rues d'aix-en-provence peuplé de
musiciens des violoncellistes aux
allures de scarabées qui regagnent leurs
lieux de répétition
renaud capuçon 22 ans a déjà entamé une
brillante carrière de soliste mais il
est entré avec joie dans la ruche de
l'académie européenne de musique qui
comptait une très agréable on passe
abbas devant et c'est souvent parce
qu'on va répéter dans ce cas les miniers
l'avons fait toutes les répétitions ont
lieu parce que steve a eue on est
tellement nous étions à peu près 250 ici
et on se retrouve sur les chemins et
c'est vraiment un dieu le mieux le
cligno du festival
très cool quoi ça très bien chacune de
ces avis on est
et la pampa région c'est claudio abbado
qui a choisi renaud capuçon comme maître
de concert pour leurs questions de
chambre du mahler ochestra l'académie
d'aix permet aux jeunes de bénéficier
des conseils des aînés illustres comme
pierre boulez et ce n'est pas le moindre
des avantages dans cette aventure
renault violon solo donne le la mais une
heure plus tard on participe à un
concert non négligeable quand on a entre
15 et 25 ans on peut rentrer le soir
après neuf heures de répétition il ya
une espèce de frénésie qui se met en
place on a toujours envie de lire un
section de brahms quatuor better ou une
partita de bach dans un jardin
romantique
mais à présent nous vous retrouvons
bruno alba mais cette fois ci dans un
autre lieu hautement représentatif la
place de l'archevêché
oui où l'on va se bousculer tout à
l'heure je vous préviens tout de suite
qu'il n'y aura pratiquement plus de
places pour assister ce soir à la
représentation de l'orfeo de monteverdi
l'orfeo qui est en fait le premier opéra
de l'histoire de la musique
alors ce nous le découvrirons ce soir
dans une mise en scène très étonnante de
la chorégraphe américaine trisha brown
elle a fait travailler les chanteurs et
les choristes qui danse sur scène sans
parler d'un face à face presque irréelle
entre orphée et eurydice emmené dans
l'au delà
cela étant le festival d'aix cette année
c'est aussi le début des retrouvailles
entre les aixois et le festival jusqu'à
présent il se sentait un peu exclu
désormais ils ont la possibilité
d'assister outre les représentations aux
répétitions qui se tiennent dans les
différents lieux de concert et où
georges bégoua consiste acte a constaté
pardon que ces spectacles faisait salle
comble le croirez-vous on refuse du
monde pour assister en compagnie de
régine crespin non pas à un spectacle
nous à une leçon de chant les aixois ont
cette année un passeport paient 100
francs et il en profite ce passe moi mon
père mais quoi
il permet d'assister à des concerts à
des répétitions de concerts à des master
class je trouve que pour les quatre
quelque chose de très intéressant parce
que c'est vrai qu'on s'est retrouvé
coupé dit festival à 1900 francs la
place au château là haut ça fait trop
alors là c'est le ici c'est le festival
du pauvre n'exagérons pas etc ce n'est
pas tout à fait marseille il y a des
places plus abordable
trente ans régime très fort qui donne
les nuances qui fait c'est fabuleux de
voir un professeur devant nous et le
résultat est tout la faute en double je
ris je chante jarrige changé je me black
nous redonne cet enthousiasme par
exemple je ne chante plus et puis tu
trombi à l'erreur de offert mais eux ils
me font dire à gilles me motive si vous
voulez ça me ça m'intéresse de leur
apprendre des choses de leur faire
remarquer les shows de leur donner le
goût du métier du travail viennent fait
de leur dire de ne pas se monter la tête
un succès pourtant le succès est au
rendez-vous et ces jeunes chanteurs
connaîtront sans doute un jour la cour
de l'archevêché où le festival joue la
carte de la jeunesse
alors l'homme du renouveau du festival
d'aix et est avec vous stéphane lissner
bonsoir soir ses fans espèrent comment
est-ce qu'on peut retoucher
l'intouchable c'est à dire une
institution comme aix en provence dans
l'idée c'est de ces de s'appuyer aussi
sur les fondations de ce festival c'est
donc de s'appuyer essentiellement sur la
naissance de ce festival juste après la
seconde guerre et sur l'idée d'un homme
gabriel dussurget qui a su en en
quelques années faire de ce lieu un
grand festival international
donc j'ai beaucoup beaucoup réfléchi
mais beaucoup travaillé sur le projet
qu'il avait mis en place et je me suis
largement inspiré en ce qui concernait
découverte des jeunes en ski couverte en
ce qui concerne l'intégration du
festival dans la ville
donc on a travaillé beaucoup sur ce
thème mais l'ouverture du festival hors
de ses propres murs c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important cause
oui pour moi c'était très important que
le festival ne soit pas réservée d'abord
à une élite c'était très important que
les aixois se sentent concernés par le
festival et le fait d'avoir créé cette
académie européenne de musique d'avoir
ouvert à 70 concerts environ 70
répétition publique récital master-class
c'était l'idée que le tout public
pouvait venir
et grâce à un passeport de 100 francs on
savait qu'on allait pouvoir très
facilement permettra au plus grand
nombre de venir dans toutes ses salles
et les sujets qu'on vient de voir le
montre ils ont répondu présent je pense
qu'on aura à peu près 20 25 mille
personnes qui auront qui seront rentrés
dans tous ces lieux
alors je voudrais qu'on s'arrête un
instant et que nous regardions un
extrait de coeur lui au river l'opéra
d'un classique du xxème siècle puisqu'il
s'agit de benjamin britten nous allons
voir les images
il s'agit d'un
d'un opéra contemporain donc qui est
absolument magnifique
mais
corsair ou des services publics le rôle
de service public c'est bien évidemment
d'explorer toutes les musiques et
surtout de ne pas nier la musique du
xxème siècle donc ce soir nous allons
donner une représentation d'orfeo et
nous avons exactement à la même heure
dans un autre lieu
car le river de britton qui est une
oeuvre qui est peu donné et qui
justement elle est donné par l'ensemble
de la troupe européenne donc 17
académies
alors les gens qui viennent à
aix-en-provence voit ses spectacles ils
sont nombreux certes mais on peut se
dire un tel investissement pour si peu
de monde
est ce qu'il y aura la possibilité de
les revoir ensuite ses spectacles à
écouter je crois qu'on peut donner
quelques chiffres si vous voulez nous
allons jouer environ 45 représentations
d'opéras ici nous allons du contenu nous
allons atteindre à peu près donc environ
30000 spectateurs mais ensuite tous ses
spectacles la plupart des spectacles
vont partir en tournée à travers
l'europe à travers la france et nous
atteindre nous aurons à peu près je
pensais festival aura à peu près 100 160
à 180 milles spectateurs sur toute
l'année car après le festival ça
continue voilà alors pour nous quitter
je vous propose de regarder et d'écouter
encore béatrice avec avec vous aussi
l'image absolument extraordinaire de
cette jeune chanteuse qui chante la mort
de didon et enée c'est l'un des très
beaux spectacles de cette version 98 du
festival d'aix-en-provence
avant de refermer ce journal les
collections de la haute couture avec
donatella versace qui a pris la
succession de son frère gianni disparu
il ya tout juste un an nicolas cornu
langlois et bernard que nord ont assisté
aux répétitions
elle était l'une des meilleures amies de
jane mythe no me campbell est présent
pour la première collection couture de
donatella pour rassurer peut-être cette
petite soeur qui fut pendant vingt ans
la collaboratrice est l'inspiratrice de
jenny et qui assurent la relève d'abord
avec prêt-à-porter versus est
aujourd'hui avec l'atelier versace
d'escoto collection f the one à la
collection couture et celles qui me
tient le plus à coeur parce que c'est à
paris que gianni présente à l'année
dernière en juillet sa dernière
collection mais aussi parce que comme
moi c'est la création la plus libre que
j'ai fait c'est exactement ce que j'ai
envie de voir porté par les femmes une
collection pleine d'invention grâce à 46
lice internationaux qui ont apporté leur
modernité
il faut être en accord avec le monde
contemporain être au courant de ce qui
se fait dans le cinéma la musique les
arts et suivre l'évolution de la
technologie dans notre travail des
mélanges audacieux et des découpes
provocatrice émotions et angoisses des
répétitions sous le regard de santo le
frère aîné
et heureusement après le final
enthousiasme de tous les collaborateurs
et des amis proches comme melanie
griffith et sa petite fille et se soient
grands succès du défilé officiel devant
les professionnels
pari gagné pour donna tellement
la fin de ce journal je vous en rappelle
le principal titre l'exclusion de
l'équipe festina du tour de france les
larmes de richard virenque qui se voit
contrainte d'abandonner le tour
une décision spectaculaire après l'aveu
d'un dopage organisé au sein de cette
équipe
dans un instant la météo isabelle
martinet belle journée pour dinan
température à la hausse je vous remercie
de votre attention
excellente descente soirée sur france
bleu